[Music]
everybody is Charlie I've got a lot of
requests to do a video for marbles what
if so this is gonna be my breakdown of
the Comic Con footage that they showed
off in Hall age an explainer for the
series in episode 1 because most of the
footage that they showed off was from
the first episode we're doing the
Avengers end game in spider-man far from
home blu-ray giveaways all you have to
do to enter that is be a subscriber and
leave your favorite what if story on the
video it can be any what-if story what
if spider-man wore the Infinity Gauntlet
what if Wolverine fought Thanos anything
that you want to see them do on this
series during multiple seasons because
one of the good things about them doing
this animated is that it's way easier
for them to do crazy stuff and for them
to do multiple seasons because they can
just cycle in new actors from the MCU
for new episodes every single season
Marvel and their lawyers didn't allow us
to record the footage inside Hall H they
were super banning everyone so I'll try
to break this down the best I can
jeffrey wright explained a little bit
about what the watcher is going to be
doing during the series if you didn't
see that news during comic-con jeffrey
wright will be the voice of the watcher
you've probably seen him on Westworld or
a bunch of other series he's an amazing
actor he has his great voice so it'll be
really cool he talked a little bit
during the panel about what the watcher
is going to be doing when he arrives in
the series for the first time but he's
been there this whole time that's kind
of the joke is that he's been watching
but every once in a while he will
intervene when he's not supposed to
because technically they're just
supposed to watch the footage that they
showed off in the first episode was the
events of the original Captain America
movie Captain America First Avenger they
were getting ready to give the Super
Soldier Serum to someone but because
this is what if it's all about alternate
events what would happen if things had
gone down very differently so it's what
it Peggy Carter had gotten the Super
Soldier Serum and what if Steve Rogers
had worn an Iron Man suit designed by
Howard Stark and because obviously this
is during the 1940s it would've looked
something more like the Iron Man mark
one very old-timey the footage basically
plays out like the scene where Captain
America is in the device Peggy Carter
comes out and she's super beefed up then
they also teased Marvel Zombies
but they zoomed in on the logo so that
you could actually see it and when you
look at that really carefully you can
actually see the Marvel Zombies from the
comics embedded in the actual logo for
the series meaning you can put some good
money on them doing Marvel Zombies
during one of these stories so it's
gonna be six to eight episodes right now
we only know about what fiber them is
going to be the Russos actually pitched
their Wolverine what if Avengers
endgames story I'll play that clip in a
second because it's actually pretty
badass there hasn't been a what-if
series in the Marvel Universe before
they haven't even done this as an
animated show before but they did do a
what-if episode on HS of shield during
season 4 it's what if agents of Hydra
they all wake up inside this simulation
where the world is completely different
and they're all agents as part of shield
it was never toppled during Winter
Soldier Hydra continued along their
plans they were successful in taking
over shield completely and then overtly
taking over the world and turning it
into this big police state we got where
there may be an attempt to steal it
sorry captain I can't give me the set
I'm gonna have to call the director
that's okay
trust me
later the only showed us about 25 of the
MCU actors that are gonna be reprising
their roles during the episodes they'll
be more than that but they were trying
to keep a couple secrets like the Marvel
Zombies thing is supposed to be a bit of
a secret so just going down to list six
there's gonna be a black panther episode
with kill monger coming back in black
panther what if kill monger had been
successful stayed king of Wakanda
incentive I brainian weapons all over
the world so it's basically the story of
Wakanda slowly taking over the world
five there's the Captain America episode
that I already explained Peggy Carter
getting in Super Soldier Serum Captain
America getting an Iron Man suit they
have young Howard Stark Arnim Zola dr.
Erskine the Howling Commandos coming
back the winter soldiers coming back for
that but he's probably coming back as
Bucky because it's all about the origin
of Captain America but it's Peggy Carter
instead of being Steve Rogers for
there's a Thanos guardians of the galaxy
episode they have fan o's coming back
nebula kragle n' kaurav john do in taser
phase which i think is interesting
because he wasn't really big during the
first guardians film but that's where we
got all that Thanos material this sounds
like it's gonna explore what happens if
Thanos was successful in getting the
Infinity stones earlier whereas the
guardians were able to steal the Power
Stone from him but that's only a small
part of the cast so just be Thanos
during that period trying to collect the
Infinity stones using nebula in Gamora 3
there's a Thor episode with Thor Loki
Korg the Grand Master the Hulk in Jane
Foster coming back they didn't say which
period this was gonna take place during
but because Korg is there and the Grand
Master I'm assuming this has something
to do with Jane Foster getting stuck on
Sekar and it's sort of teasing leading
up into the plot of Thor 4 because even
though these are animated all the TV
shows will influence what happens in the
movies so even though the concept might
sound weird these technically alternate
reality alternate timeline what-if
episodes will also influence what
happens in the movies but I think it's
mostly to prepare you for some of the
story twists that are coming in upcoming
movies like the Wanda visions show
getting into the idea of the multiverse
so that when they go full multiverse
during Doctor Strange in the multiverse
of madness it doesn't seem so weird to
there's an ant-man in the wasp episode
with ant-man Hank Pym the
contine coming back I'm also assuming
hope Van Dyne wasp will come back too
it's either gonna be what if
yellowjacket was successful in
syndicating the Yellowjackets all over
the world and selling them to all those
terrorist organizations or then getting
stuck in the quantum realm which seems a
little more exciting just because the
quantum realm is such a big question
mark then number one I think the biggest
episode we're all looking forward to is
an Avengers Marvel Zombies story they
haven't said who's gonna star in that
but they'll be very Avengers centric
like Hawkeye is coming back for some of
these series so there'll be a lot of
other actors they'll announce when they
start getting ready to produce the
episodes all the Russos were actually
talking about some of this stuff they
did talk about a what-if scenario with
Wolverine during avengers endgame so
this is the clip of them talking about
that or there might be some compelling
well let's start out with they're not
quite in the same universe but here are
the X some of them there's actually like
70 of them but who would we take out and
who would we leave this is gonna be
interesting
yeah I'm gonna do something very
controversial you know it's a bold
choice
all right listen it's not like you take
a group and then like randomly that
group loses half of its members right
the Hawkeye's entire family disappears
yeah so any given group you could lose
almost everyone in that group that's
what happen the only one who's left you
was halfway all the excellent except for
Wolverine that's right gambit that's
right dammit rules there's a lot of
people that rule they get snapped away
scarcely motivated Wolverine going up
against Thanos this is great that would
be a pretty cool movie if you've been
following the news the Russos actually
did say separately that they would come
back to Marvel to do a Wolverine movie
but they've also said the same thing
about Secret Wars so now we got two big
movies on the list that they'll come
back for but it's probably gonna be a
couple years before they get to
something like that so just daydream
about what a Russo
others Wolverine x-men movie looks like
they did say that not all these series
are going to get second seasons it's
just that what-if is a little bit easier
for them to produce because you can
rotate the cast of every single episode
every single time like each of the
episodes will be a different event in a
different part of the timeline in the
MCU the other really cool detail that
this confirms about the Hulk that I
suspected is is that they can do the
Hulk on TV there's no big rights issue
with Universal if you've been following
the saga of Hulk films the reason why
Marvel has not been able to release a
Hulk film since the Incredible Hulk is
because they don't have a deal with
Universal anymore Universal has the
rights to distribute Hulk films that's
why they distributed the Incredible Hulk
film way back during phase 1
theoretically Disney and Marvel Studios
could make a Hulk solo film but they
don't have the rights to distribute it
they would have to go to Universal for
that and if Universal didn't agree to it
then the film would just sit on a shelf
collecting dust so Disney isn't gonna
spend a hundred and fifty million
dollars on a film that it can't release
itself so that's why there is no Hulk
phone coming Mark Ruffalo has been
really down on it there's this funny
clip of Don Cheadle just giving him a
whole bunch of [ __ ] about it I want to
just make one thing perfectly clear
today a standalone Hulk movie will never
happen because Universal has the rights
to the standalone Hulk movie and for
some reason they don't know how to play
well with Marvel and they don't want to
make money and with you as the new Hulk
I mean I figure I got like two or three
more years left to further I'm too old
to play the whole you as much of a
bummer as that is because they can do
the hook on TV now confirmed because of
this what-if series that means that they
can pay off the Red Hulk deleted scene
from Avengers end game even though the
version of Red Hulk during that scene
was very different from the comics they
could actually do an Incredible Hulk
episode what if general Ross became Red
Hulk during the Incredible Hulk film
instead of Bruce Banner but all that
what if is only the tip of the iceberg
like what if dr. strange had failed to
stop Dormammu during the Doctor Strange
movie what if Peter quill had not killed
ego the living
planet what if Quicksilver had not died
during Avengers age of Ultron
what if Iron Man had become sort of
supreme I hope they do that at some
point that was one of the more fun
what-if stories that they then brought
back around during Marvel legacy the
much older version of Tony Stark in the
distant future eventually becomes
sorcerer supreme so everybody posts your
ideas for what if episodes inside the
MCU and you can use any characters you
want
Deadpool the Fantastic Four characters
the x-men characters like Wolverine
right now the biggest rumor that I've
been seeing floating around is that
black panther will be the first film
where we actually see some of those Fox
Marvel characters showing up but not
necessarily the ones you would expect
like we're talking more about Namor and
he's kind of a brand-new thing I've
already done a black panther - Namor
Easter Egg video because there that
really special seen during avengers
endgame so I'll link that at the end of
this I'll name a giveaway winner when I
post new Marvel I'm still working on
that eternals video everybody click here
for that black panther - Namor Easter
Egg video and click here for the boys
season 2 teaser trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]